when to bring a fox news alert
Democratic Senator Mark Warner of
Virginia Fox News has learned texted
with a Russian oligarch lobbyist in an
effort to contact the author of the
Trump dossier Christopher Steele because
you can't make this up Fox News's ed
Henry has this story need joins us with
details hey ed well Tucker good to see
these texts obtained exclusively by Fox
News they show and you can see them
right here I have them that Senator Mark
Warner a Democrat who's been leading one
of the investigations of president
Trump's ties to Russia had extensive
contact with that lobbyist for an Oleg
Ark who offered him access to steal who
of course wrote the dossier Warner text
it at one point he would quote rather
not have a paper trail in case he could
not seal an agreement with the former
British spy to testify steal so far has
not agreed to interview with the Senate
Intel panel he began Warner did texting
with this lobbyist Adam Waldman in
February 2017 about getting testimony
from Russian billionaire Oleg Deripaska
who had his visa revoked by the State
Department because of charges that he
has ties to Russian organized crime
Warner wanted to connect directly with
Steele without anyone else being in the
loop at least at first quote we have so
much to discuss you need to be careful
but we can help our country Warner
texted Waldman on March 22nd I'm in
Waldman who has a firm with ties to
Hillary Clinton texted back now wobba
noted Steele was concerned about media
leaks so Warner sent another text quote
we want to do this right private in
London don't want to send a letter yet
because if we can't get agreement would
rather not have paper trail now the
panel the Senate Intel panel got these
texts from Waldman last September after
they asked for him and a Warner eight
acknowledged that Warner and Richard
Burr the Republican chairman revealed
the text of their colleagues because
quote they realized out of context it
doesn't look great for Warner but Warner
number stressed to Fox in a statement
tonight that the chairman of the
committee Richard Burr was in the loop
about all this Waldman by the way did
not return calls seeking comment
he signed a $40,000 a month retainer in
20 2009 and 2010 to petition the US
government on behalf of that Russian
billionaire that that billionaire by the
way is supposed to have ties to Paul
Manafort
is why the committee wanted to get to
him but remember this investigated
investigation started with these various
committees and now robert muller looking
at the president's ties to russians now
it's being turned around a little bit on
democrats chuckle a little bit doesn't
look good with it when a president says
he doesn't what a senator says he
doesn't want quote a paper trail that's
not good
and thank you for that whose great story
thanks